as Americans raise for the medical and
economic impacts of the coronavirus US
officials are trying to encourage
preparedness without setting off a panic
joining us now dr. Anthony Fauci
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases dr.
welcome back to Fox News Sunday good to
be with you Chris what's the latest on
the spread of the corona virus across
the country and the number of deaths
here well we're having obviously an
acceleration of cases now if you look at
it every day we get more and more we
have somewhere around 350 350 probably
going to be close to 400 if it isn't
already there we have at least 18 deaths
and they keep coming on every day that
goes by what we're seeing is with what
is called community spread in certain
regions of the country particularly in
the area of Washington State Seattle
yeah so Italy just announced that it is
going to lock down an entire region of
northern Italy that includes Milan and
Venice with a quarter of the population
millions of people nobody's going to be
allowed except under extraordinary
circumstances to go in or to go out
right could that happen here you know we
have to be realistic I I don't think it
would be as draconian as nobody in and
nobody out but they'll be if we continue
to get cases like this particularly at
the community level there will be what
we call mitigation where you'll have to
do essentially social distancing keep
people out of crowded places take a look
at seriousness do you really need to
travel those kinds of things and I think
it's particularly important among the
most vulnerable and that's the thing
that the CDC and the State Department
are going to be making some
recommendations about how people who
have underlying conditions those are the
most vulnerable particularly elderly
with underlying conditions heart disease
chronic lung disease diabetes to do
right now not wait
but right now to sort of take a look at
things that are at high risk crowded
places getting on airplanes and
absolutely don't get on a cruise ship so
I'm gonna press this question though of
Italy could could you see a situation
you know you would lead a lot of talk
about Seattle and
what's going on there we're a city is
shut down or a state or a region is shut
down and you basically just say for and
in the case of Italy is still April 3rd
nobody in nobody out
it's possible I think what you need to
do on real-time basis and that's the
reason why we evaluate it literally
every single day you know you don't want
to alarm people but given the spread we
see you know anything is possible and
that's the reason why we've got to be
prepared to take whatever action is
appropriate to contain and mitigate the
outbreak okay
meanwhile the the cruise ship the Grand
Princess the the latest call is that it
has a 3500 people on it that it's gonna
dock perhaps as early as tomorrow at a
non occupied dock in San Francisco Bay
people are then going to be taken off
the ship they're going to be sent to
quarantine California people to a base
in California the others to a base in
Georgia are you comfortable with that or
would you prefer to see those folks stay
on that show absolutely not I recommend
it very strongly in our meetings that we
get those people off that ship we don't
want to have a repeat of what we saw at
the Diamond Princess where the ship
became almost a hotspot of transmission
no I feel strongly about getting them
off there and getting them under the
appropriate quarantine and or care for
those who are sick there has been some
confusion about the response in this
country to the disease first of all when
a vaccine will become available take a
look I've heard very numbers a matter of
months that I've heard pretty much a
year would be an outside number
gonna be deployable and that is gonna be
at the earliest a year-to-year no matter
how fast you go realistically what's the
earliest that a vaccine will be
available for Americans to tell you I
think people need to appreciate the
difference between a vaccine that you've
proven works that's gonna take a year to
a year-and-a-half when you can get it
scaled up and that's the reason why
we've met with the pharmaceutical
companies because once you show it works
then you got to scale it up to hundreds
of millions of doses we are talking at
least a year to a year and a half at
least at best you sound like you think
it's longer than that well you know it
might be with regard I mean I Kris the
the tests we're doing right now getting
it into phase one trial is the fastest
we've ever done don't confuse that with
one you could put it in someone's arm in
a deployable way so I think that we
really need to be realized that for now
the answer is not going to be a vaccine
if in fact we go into a cycle where we
come back next year then we likely would
have some opportunity for a vaccine
there have also been contradictions
about when and how many people can get
tested take a look at that anybody that
needs a test gets a test we they're
there they have the tests and the tests
are beautiful anybody that needs a test
gets
we don't have enough tests today to meet
what we anticipate will be the demand
going forward can anybody who needs a
test get a test now the fact is the
tests are out there that was a misstep
early on with regard to the test namely
a technical difficulty but right now
about 1.1 million tests are out there
now there'll be an additional about 640
thousand on it let's say Monday and then
at least another 4 million particularly
now that we're engaging the private
sector now when you say that they're out
there if you go to a doctor it's up to
the doctor to order the tests and if
that happens a person should have a test
available but it's no doubt Chris you
have to be realistic early on there was
some missteps that delayed it I want to
pick up on that doctor and the question
of testing I want to put some numbers on
this Green as of Thursday the CDC had
tested only 1583 people in California
only 516 tests meanwhile in South Korea
more than 66,000 people were tested
within a week of the first case of
community transmission and they can now
test 10,000 people a day why are we so
far behind I think I mean it gets back
to what I said in the beginning that the
CDC made a test there was a technical
glitch there
the CDC provides tests for the public
health groups in the state and local
what we really need to do now which were
the numbers that I mentioned to you is
to get the private sector involved so
that you could literally flood it with
millions and millions of tests that is
happening now but in fact the American
people need to realize that in the
beginning there was a glitch and we need
to overcome that now you spoke with
Politico recently and I want to put a
part of what you had to say you said you
should never destroy your own
credibility and you don't want to go to
war with the president but you've got to
walk the fine balance of making sure you
continue to tell the truth you
had to correct the president a few times
especially on the availability and and
and the schedule for vaccines where do
you personally draw the line between
reassuring people but staying away from
the spin yeah I I try as best as
possible and I think I succeed over many
years of staying away from spin and just
give people the information that you
need based on evidence and hard facts
when you have the evidence you give it
as it is if you don't have all the
evidence because we're in a dynamic
situation you use your best judgment in
recommendations and guidelines but you
must always always be truthful with the
American public there's a story today on
AP that the White House overruled the
CDC which wanted to warn elderly people
and people and physically fragile
conditions not to get on Commercial
Airplanes one do you know the whether
that's true or not and two what would
you tell a relative of yours who was in
either in that class either elderly or
physically fragile would you say stay
off airplanes no well here's the deal I
can tell you right away Chris that no
one overruled anybody about saying this
so let me say it loud and clear now the
CDC has a Health Alert and the State
Department has more of a travel alert
right now I'm telling the American
people based on everything that's agreed
upon in the taskforce that if you are an
individual who has an underlying
condition particularly an elderly person
with an underlying condition right now
not wait you should start to distance
yourself from the risk crowds getting on
a plane on a long plane trip and above
all don't get on a cruise ship that is a
health issue what the State Department
is is saying from analogist extend point
don't get on a cruise ship because you
can come out have a person on there then
all of a sudden you find yourself not
being able to get back and quarantine no
one has told us not to say that and I'm
saying it very clearly now on your show
finally I have noticed you've been all
over television the last few days you
have a bit of a raspy voice
have you tested yourself or have
yourself tested for the coronavirus my
no because I have not been at risk my
raspy voice is the fact that I'm talking
too much on TV shows well keep doing it
you are a voice of reason and science
and authority and I think when people
hear you they you're they have reason to
think they're getting this great school
thank you very much thank you for giving
me the opportunity Chris always good to
talk with you sir